tonight at 8 pm eastern time here on
c-span 3's american history tv
joan mellon is an english professor and
author of over 20 books including
several focusing on the kennedy
assassination
next on american history tv she
discusses the cia's relations with the
late 1970s house select committee on
assassinations which held hearings to
investigate the jfk and dr martin luther
king jr murders
mellon argues that the cia had covert
influence over the committee and the
writing of their final report
she spoke for about 45 minutes at a
conference marking the 50th anniversary
of the release of the warren report
hosted by the assassination archives and
research center
i want to thank jim lazar
and jerry polikov and andrew craig i
don't know if he's here
for putting on this conference i want to
say something about yesterday several
things about yesterday and that is
yesterday was a historic occasion for
this conference
and antonio vestiana said
very important things about mexico city
that we had never heard
now some people might not embrace it
right now and i was just saying to jeff
morley they might say well it might be
like somebody that thinks well suddenly
the world is not flat it's round and uh
what are we going to do about it but
this really was an extraordinary moment
it makes this conference into a historic
conference
and along that line
jerry
i like i'm a teacher you might have
noticed
uh i want to mention that the uh
interview with antonio vestiana
yesterday was made possible for us
largely
by gordon winslow of miami
and it was neglected to give gordon the
credit for that yesterday he certainly
deserves it for putting for putting that
together
so i think many people know gordon he's
been in miami for
much time
all right
i uh
want to talk about the issues that were
raised yesterday at the conference
and
my topic is
the
cia penetration of the house select
committee on assassinations
i want to mention several i wanted to
note
john woman's talk yesterday where john
talked about the importance of names
and he gave all the different uh
pseudonyms of david atlee phillips
sloman sforza and so forth well some
things were wrong about the names
yesterday
one of the world one of the mistakes in
the names
was that when the word carlos brigniere
that's a person who scuffled with lee
harvey oswald on the streets of new
orleans
when premiere should have been named
instead the synonym was substituted
d-r-e
brigade had joined dra but he was not
responsible to the leadership of dre
dre repudiated him they had to
acknowledge that he was theirs once this
assassination occurred
but when i went to see the leadership of
dre
i asked about bringing air and
what relationship he had with them
and juan salvat who was one of the three
founding members of dre
said he told me
we have no problem with mr garrison
carlos bernier who's written a new book
lately i gather colonel springer was
responsible and reported to the fbi ncia
in new orleans
if you doubt me you can find all those
documents in the national archives he
was not responsible or reporting to dre
in miami
so that's another name there are a
couple of other names that i'd like to
first set out another name is the person
who really subverted the house select
committee
he's from cia's end his name is scott
breckenridge
and if you want to know about scott
brecker his his documents are also all
available available
in the national archives and i'll quote
some of them in a few minutes
and there's another name that i learned
about because i became very friendly
with the new orleans and the louisiana
investigators for the house select
committee who was doing the
investigations in louisiana
and that name which i heard briefly
yesterday
was harold leap
howard leap was a cia man planted in the
house select committee investigation and
he was there to subvert the interviews
how do i know that i know that because
my book a farewell to justice is
dedicated to robert euros who was of new
orleans police intelligence and was one
member of the team
of the louisiana team that that did that
investigation and he told me that he was
so angry at leap that one time he just
got in the car and drove as fast as he
could over a waterway you know there's a
lot of water in the wounds
and
the leap is scared and hanging on and he
got some satisfaction out of that leap
destroyed many of the interviews that
burris did
so that's for starters and i'm really
and i wanted oh i wanted to mention
something else
my sources not only huge archive in the
national archives but also the people to
whom i spoke personally and directly one
was bringing air
and if you think that was pleasant
you know
it wasn't because he was hostile and i
have to tell you one thing about
bringing here that you might not know
when he first came to the united states
that he told me this the first thing
that he did was he used to go to
demonstrations take pictures of the
demonstrators find out their names and
walk over to the fbi and hand them in
there
that's who bring yours
not a deal no who are the dre
so i went down to miami miami and i
started interviewing gre one of them the
the most articulate perhaps was juan
salva salvate who's a publisher runs a
publishing house on
in miami
and he and you see drew borja and
several of them they told me how much
they despised cia
they were not any pawns of cia they they
hated
helms
and kennedy equally they didn't want to
kill president kennedy the word that we
need for dre is paramilitary
they were paramilitary fighters they
wanted to disrupt cuba they wanted to
destabilize the society they burned they
bombed a theater called blanquette i
think and uh and that's they didn't care
about anything else they didn't want to
kill president kennedy they had no
interest in that whatsoever nor did they
ever have any interest in oswald
so to say that george joe anita
subverted the house select committee
investigation
because he was once a handler of of dre
is really not true not just not true at
all
joe amides is a very minor cog in that
machine
very small
the big person in charge was scott
breckenridge and he was from the office
of legal counsel of cia not some little
business
and he went right through editing the
hsca final report to the end to the last
day
what about the first day now nobody here
another other names that have not been
mentioned
are richard sprague and bob tannenbaum
when they took over the house select
committee the rule that they put in play
was never to have anyone sorry connected
to cia to work for the investigation
i just want to
turn to that
no one having anything to no one
connected to cia would have anything to
do with their investigation why not
because cia was a suspect
when sprague led the investigation among
his guidelines was no one hire
either from fbi cia or any federal
agency because quote to do a thorough
investigation these agencies actions
have to be part of the investigation
under robert blakey there were cia
people embedded in hsca among them as i
just mentioned harold leap
cia was not going to permit the hsca to
conduct its investigation unimpeded
from the day that richard sprague left
and i think that everybody who followed
him should have known what was coming
henry gonzalez chairman of the committee
told cia to ignore the subpoenas should
the committee present any
when cia demanded security checks on
everyone who has permitted access to the
documents sprague refused was it the
case later i'll be damned if they'll
investigate us before we investigate
them sprague's deputy robert k
tannenbaum declared
cia then marshaled its media and
congressional assets to accuse breg of
trampling on people's rights
the same charge the agency leveled
against jim garrison
i heard that pot shot yesterday against
jim garrison so unnecessary by an author
who said something that wasn't true
about garrison which was that garrison
um
met with johnny roselli in las vegas in
april 1967. garrison never met with
johnny roselli
and that was just one way and i think
helms in his interview with the church
committee admits that it was his idea to
accuse garrison of having met with
roselli
well
then set roselli got on the stand
and roselli said i never met the man
i've seen him on television but but i've
never met him
but you know once the damage is done
not yesterday at the church committee
johnny roselli
sorry it was anthony summers
here you mean here
summers
i mean i don't know i mean if you if you
find out that you're wrong about
something have the good grace
just like in mexico city whatever we
thought or wrote about mexico city
antonio veziana has given us
a pretty final word on that leno we
don't know all the details but we know a
lot more than we knew before for sure
all right
and i have a quote here from richard
case nagal not maybe your favorite but
miguel who was talking about the hsca
and said nobody there really wants the
truth which i think was pretty well
known
i also want to mention an incident that
was published in jim the eugenio's
magazine probe i believe
and it had a former supreme court
justice arthur goldberg
expressed his willingness to take
sprague's place
in a well-known telephone conversation
to cia director stansfield turner
goldberg said he would serve under the
condition of full c i a cooperation
his comment was met by turner's silence
goldberg repeated his concerns
i thought my silence was my answer
turner said
very serious from then on cia ran the
show no joe needs anywhere in any of
this scenario
he's an apparatchik he's sent there by
helms to deal with the documents but he
certainly isn't the subverter of the
investigation itself far from it
now jerry pollakov has appeared on the
scene spelling my name wrong one more
time
it's sort of like a vaudeville isn't it
it's all right don't worry
from then on cia ran the show
chief robert blakey cut a deal with cia
the first day date july 27 1977
when blakey and larry strauterman cia's
information and privacy coordinator
finalized their arrangement
strodeman wrote out the terms of cia's
control of blakey's investigation
certain areas relating to the
assassination of president kennedy he
decreed should be entirely disregarded
based upon our contention that they are
without merit or corroboration
the arbiter of the value of any piece of
evidence was going to be cia
now the committee capitulated to every
agency's stricture
blakey accepted that they should be
quote sanitized materials that documents
be kept kept top secret and eyes only
see on cia scrutinize the notes well
this i think
eddie lopez told us yesterday cia
scrutinized the notes of the
investigators who were permitted to look
at cia documents in the closed room
a non-disclosure agreement would silence
certain house select committee
investigators and lawyers quote in
perpetuity
forever
now the other my other source on this
were as i said before lj delsa and
robert burus both
detectives and
police investigators from new orleans
and they went to washington and they
were going to really do it
and uh they never kept the silence no no
just non-disclosure agreements they just
went to jim garrison finally and said
judge
this is going nowhere
and garrison said just keep going as
long as you can
and the truth will come out
some truth came out yesterday i mean i
have to say so truth will come out but
not if you uh don't stand up to cia
that's not going to happen and or blame
it on some underling like joey needs
so
cia and i as i asked eddie lopez
yesterday cia controlled what questions
the committee could pose to agency
assets in particular bernardo de torres
who would be immortal by the way
immortalized in kennedy assassination
literature as deleopoldo who visited
silvia odeon
a law in the company of a person named
angelo mergato took five years more six
years for us to try to pry that
information out of the source
at first he said angelo
so we say angelo who
five years later we got who the angela
was and angelo of course knew who
leopoldo was so we had both of them some
people still don't believe it
well again the earth is round
um okay and eddie didn't remember
yesterday that quite the what's what
eddie remembered as i did and that gait
and fonzie told me was that cia told the
committee exactly what time period they
could ask questions of of bernardo de
torres and then the fbi came in
separately and told them a different
time period they're not allowed to ask
anything about that
and if look if de torres is leopoldo
coming to sylvia odios in the company of
leon oswald
he's worth talking to isn't he without
restrictions
what do you have to lose
you know where this it's in our heads in
our behalf that these investigations are
being made
uh
otherwise went to gate and fonzie who
was such a gentleman and never reacted
at all but he was lied to a lot during
uh ted shackley of the uh running i
think jm wave at the time insisted that
uh jm wave had been quote only
interested in pursuing its intelligence
gathering and propaganda
missions
shades of 1946 and 1947 that was never
the case
cia continued to control the house
select committee investigation no joe
news when delsa and buras subjected cia
asset thomas edward beckham to a
polygraph that was done in new orleans
they were suspended they were shocked
you didn't get permission i think it was
gary cornwell who did that they that you
didn't get permission
they couldn't believe it and what they
wanted to do what they really wanted to
do was after the polygraph of thomas
edward beckham who was in on november
2nd 22nd 1963 at the school book
depository we won't go into that right
now but pretty good evidence on that
what they wanted to do was to proceed to
an investigation of a person named fred
lee chrisman
who had taken beckham who was sort of he
was the handler of beckham and taking
him to a place in omaha nebraska that
you know well
alfred air force base
and and chrisman had died but they had
wanted to go on with that investigation
they were not permitted to do so they
were shut down on that
and there's a lot more of this too it's
i think it's interesting um
beerus and delta were then separated the
two of them together was it was not
going to happen
so when burus visited clinton in jackson
clinton that just for those who don't
know the whole story clinton and jackson
were two towns north of baton rouge
where oswald was seen in the company of
two cia assets clay shaw proven by the
cia history group we took gary aguila
helped me with that we talked about
about that a year ago
and uh
david ferry and clay shaw and oswald
so what happens that
hsca decides and they don't need joe and
edie's to do this they decide that
they're not allowed that is first of all
burus was separated from delsa buress
went up there with somebody named
patricia orr
whose name you might know and orr said
you cannot interview anyone up here who
has not already been interviewed by the
garrison investigation
i don't know what that means or why that
is but that's what they said and one of
the people that was not in interviewed
by the garrison investigation
was frank silva the direct medical
director of the east louisiana state
hospital at jackson
and he see also oswald there
talking about how he was going to kill
fidel castro
so uh we don't get that
the committee didn't have it they
couldn't use it
um
yeah beerus was also forbidden and the
people who know the garrison's story
know this material i don't know if gmt
genio is in the room or not virus was
forbidden to explore any possible
contact between guy bannister and alvin
and lloyd cobb who are also up north of
baton rouge you could not look into
marijuana farms
i'm sorry
oh
god like lower like this
lower still
i need bill simpick to help me
okay
i'll repeat that then
yours could not look into contact
between guy bannister and alvin and
lloyd cobb
he could not look into maridel farms and
whether fairy shaw and oswald had made
an appearance there as was suspected
delsa interviewed warren de bruys whom
i've talked about in other places and
de bruijs said that he you know he knew
that john quigley had consulted de
bruijs when i remember when oswald was
arrested on canal street and he went to
the police station and he caught he
asked
francis martello who was in charge
please call the fbi and tell them you
have lee oswald in custody
so
uh
oswald said i want to speak to debruce
ruiz refused and so that was why john
quigley went down there and as you
probably know he burnt his notes he said
he burnt his notes
as cia infiltrated the hsca
investigation beerus was required to do
his interviews in the company as of this
person and i mentioned harold leap whom
he discovered was cia's man on the
committee
so it was leap who went with burus to
interview former fbi clerk william
walter now marta was the clerk who
picked up the telephone at the fbi that
day when oswald had francis martello
call
leap's interruptions during the walter
interview
were met with walter's indignation
i know what i know and i know what i saw
walter said oswald had enough informants
status with our office now we know that
now but at the time that was that was
very new material
while when beerus and lee interviewed
william go day who i think his name was
mentioned yesterday
we circumvented the crucial questions
leap would not permit bureaus to ask cia
asset go day who edited a newsletter
you've heard of the latin american
reports out of clay shaw's international
trademark
why his name why was goday's name just
before oswald's obliterated from the
list of people you know about this going
getting mexican tourist cards that had
been sent to the warren commission
later hsca lawyer robert gunsman asked
o'day whether his relationship with cia
quote like shaw's
was purely informational
the question contained the answer that
goday was expected to give
healthy
um
the question contained the answer that
goday was expected to give no goday said
defiantly he did certain chores for them
that were not
informational hsca deposed goday as a
protected witness
with the committee being instructed by
cia's frank carlucci on what they could
and could not ask him
angry goday then went into a riff on
cia's having lied on documents with
respect to the end dates of his service
with them
one document said 1961 another said 1969
i never did end my relationship with
c.i.a goday said
even jaylee rankin the senior counsel
for the warren commission admitted that
he had learned a bitter lesson he told
the hsca he regretted he had taken the
cia's word that oswald was never a cia
agent
by the time burus and leap interviewed
another cia asset jack rogers buress had
given up and didn't bother to ask rogers
any questions
i might also mention the sarcastic and
belligerent tone of some of the hsca
interviews and you can't lay this on
joanie's joe anita's door
particularly one of thomas edward
beckham where the questioner insinuates
that since beckham knew clay shaw
he must also be a homosexual
interviewed by an hsca lawyer william
walter was threatened with legal action
by the fbi because he must be lying
both beckham and walter were treated as
hostile witnesses with no objective but
to undermine their testimony and their
bona fides
now i would direct your attention again
listen homeless to a bunch of cia memos
residing at the national archives by the
way i want to say something if anybody
wants to reinvestigate this that would
be a great idea
go down to miami the same gordon winslow
that made the possible the interview
yesterday with carlos festiana will help
you
go to c1 salvador go to see isidro borja
even go to new orleans and see bringing
air go to the national archives and look
at these records
and i think you'll you'll see some very
different picture from the
self-justification that we heard about
how it is all the fault of the fact that
joe andes was a hand handler of c of uh
dre
dre i think that
craig dandrew wanted me to say
directorio
revolucionario estudiante
okay i would direct your attention to a
bunch of cia memos residing at the
national archives that reveal the
agency's persistent efforts to control
the wording of the house select
committee's final report
most of these were authored by scott
breckenridge coming out of the as i said
the office i hope i said of office of
legal counsel high up
in cia
i see no evidence that any of the hsca
leadership stood up to breckenridge
rejecting his quote suggestions or that
his interference was rejected as
entirely
inappropriate on one page five single
space memo from breckenridge to robert
blakey
was dated september 27 1978.
writing on behalf of the director of
central intelligence breckenridge
complains about hsca's questioning of
richard helms
irregularities in cia's 20101 file of
lee harvey oswald had led to questions
not least why no file was seemingly open
we all know this right seemingly opened
for oswald for 14 months after his
october 1959 defection to the soviet
union helms had been questioned by hsca
lawyer michael goldsmith goldsmith
inspiring the agency's fury that blakey
should not honor helms's plausible
deniability nothing was good enough for
them
a man of such senior position in a large
organization
would obviously be unfamiliar with the
sort of details asked him breckenridge
writes in a hectoring letter
his subtext is that blakey had better
get his staff under control
breckenridge insists that there are
quote reasonable and convincing
explanations for the oddities in the
agency's records on oswald
i find the nature of the questioning
disturbing breckenridge writes as if
hsca were under cia jurisdiction
mr goldsmith's performance on these
points was tendentious at best he
introduced material into the record that
we knew or that he had reason to know to
be different from the way he elected to
present it
this careful construction
this careful construction
of a floored record cannot serve the
purpose of an objective investigation
the agency demanded that blakey accept
its denials while claiming
simultaneously that cia was quote
offering cooperation
blakey had prepared had provided cia
with several drafts of his final report
in a 16-page memo to blakey again on
behalf of the director of central
intelligence
breckenridge proposes changes to a
second draft in this memo breckenridge's
tone is arrogant and dismissive
he terms the report incorrect
and attacks scornfully the investigator
of oswald's mexico city visit
who was eddie lopez
over and over breckenridge defends the
agency against the charge that it had
not informed the warren commission of
what it knew
he serves up a plethora of excuses
including that it was the fbi that was
charged with reporting to the commission
and not cia
what the agency did was to supply
material that was deemed relevant we
heard that yesterday didn't we
d r deemed relevant d d n r d not
relevant
he attacks the hsca draft for
unsupported assertions calling it quote
badly confused in its treatment of facts
and sources when he cannot refute the
fra the facts breckenridge terms the
report quote unbalanced
breckenridge deserves special contempt
for cia's john whitten also known as
john celson
the one officer who spoke frankly to the
hsca regarding the agency's maneuvers
with respect to its own ostensible
investigation of the kennedy
assassination
witness collection was quote wrong
breckenridge says in one place
in another he charges that witness
report his his italics was incorrect
breckenridge objects to the unusual
space
witness testimony was given in the hsc
report this is not because he knew
anything
breckenridge asserts but must be because
he was prepared about to speak to
prepare to speak about things
he did not know
blake blakenly blakey sorry provided cia
with several drafts of his final report
and breckenridge wrecking ridge goes on
insisting on the assertions including
the louisiana calderon 201 file
he objects to references this is
breckenridge even in the 1965 amlash
trial which we heard about yesterday
demanding that they'd be deleted
reportedly castro told the hsca that he
knew that amlash was kubella that is not
for us to confirm
breckenridge says he writes as if cia
and hsca were a single entity
in a march document breckenridge
responds to a request made by robert
flakey that cia review inserts for the
hsca draft report on antonio vestiana
cia obliged going on to accuse the hsea
investigator
gayton fonzie
of misrepresenting quote
both the relationship of cia with the
man generally described as an asset in
the proposed incent and what that man's
relationship was with
breckenridge denies that vessiana had
any tie with cia through bishop we heard
all about this yesterday
he insists that morris bishop was not of
from or with cia
he's lying to the committee
outright he argues that bishop was not
david atlee phillips no matter that dave
that gayton fonzie was able to
accumulate a wealth of corroborating
evidence some from cia officers that he
was
vestiana was an asset of another
government agency breckenridge claims
and of course we do know that uh
vessiano was both cia's am shal amshale
am shjle1 and also was with military
intelligence
i have deleted the section on this
because it is so flagrantly in error
breckenridge writes then he reveals how
blakey had contacted cia every step of
the way you plan to contact us early
this week to have a substantive exchange
on the final draft report breckenridge
writes we are available at your
convenience
less than two weeks later cia reviewed
the hsca's final draft paper evolution
and implications of the cia sponsored
assassination conspiracies against
castro here breckenridge is emboldened
to raise a personal question
on the very first paragraph
then he complains that there is more
simplistic rhetoric than mature morals
principle in the document
arguing that the writings of church
philosophers have distinguished quote
between different kinds of homicides
breckenridge invokes the red herring of
whether adolf hitler should have been
assassinated
always he presents cia as morally
impeccable its concerns narrowly
protection of intelligence sources and
methods
predictably he claims that the
devastating conclusions of the church
committee were quote erroneous
and you can help me out because i could
i as i'm gonna end here now i could
discover no record that blakey did
anything but comply
so thank you very much listening to all
that
and uh if anyone has a question
please if i can answer it if i know
enough to answer it i would be happy to
do so
i wanted to kind of lob what may be a
big old softball to you about joe and
edie's because he was i think everybody
agrees he was like the chief of
psychological warfare in miami right and
so he had a history
of doing stuff that would lead people to
lie to people
and harold leap
on the other hand i think we've got you
named a couple of instances where leap
really did a lot of dirt and so i guess
one i'm asking for more dirt on leap if
you have it but two
uh because i think it's serious i do but
on joe and edie's why are you so sure
that he didn't throw more dirt in the
game thanks i don't know i have done a
lot more than i know i mean i'm
perfectly willing to say that i don't i
wasn't there i'm only relying on my
sources which were the dre bring the air
again fonzie who spent a lot of time
with me and that's why i said yesterday
i said when i walked when eddie lopez
was here that was amazing because gayton
was always saying hey talk daddy lopez
talk to eddie lopez didn't want to talk
at that time and so he didn't and then
game called him and then gayton gave me
all these little yellow slips of paper
what cia was doing in there nothing with
joe and eddie's and look what they're
doing look what they did this is how i
circumvented it or he did or he didn't
and so those my sources told me that i
as far as i could see from what the
people have talked about the joe and
eddie's case they've talked about
documents and that joe anita's held but
that documents control documents and so
forth they didn't go out and he didn't
go out and interview people say the way
burris and delsa did
and they went and got thomas edward
beckham if you read the pharaoh of
justice you'll see him and he wouldn't
talk even oliver stone he pretended oh
ma'am i don't know who i don't know
anyone by that name and all of that and
uh and there he was it was him
so
uh he was a and then they put him in the
pod what is wrong well gary cornwell
didn't give me an official okay didn't
give us an official okay on the
polygraph polygraph was done by the new
orleans police department their best
person to do it and and by the way it
wasn't very convenient because thomas
edward beckham passed
he wasn't lying at least a few trusted
probably at least that he went that far
so i you know if there's a little dirt
that joe and eddie's did that i don't
know about i'm happy to hear it but i
think that i could see that this letter
to larry straudemann from the first day
of the blakey investigation and the fact
that bob tannenbaum quit because he
refused to have anything to do with this
investigation anymore
sort of tells us and jim garrison said
once blakey took over there was nothing
could be done anymore that was it and
then and he just waited he said all
right so we will just uh
oh thank you we'll just uh
wait it out
and uh he died waiting i guess garrison
did
but um
it's a law this is history that's why i
must say yesterday we were told about
what 1.0
2.0 and 3.0 remember that and the idea
was the digital one was three-point now
you cannot do anything with 3.0 unless
you embrace
1.0 and 2.0 and i'm sure everybody here
is interested in this issue is
interested in history and respects
history and doesn't throw away 1.0 and
2.0 uh because some there's some uh
digital help on the computer with three
point whatever that is three point so uh
i'm interested in history i mean my
favorite writer is don delilla who's
written of course a great book on oswald
called libra if anyone hasn't seen it by
any chance it's magnificent
because lee harvey oswald you know was
born in this month of october so it's
the astrological sign for october
professor please allow me to interrupt
for just one moment uh we'd like to do
questions up until noon at which time we
are going to stop on a dime so that you
all have an opportunity to have lunch
and to return
uh for a presentation from
uh professor g robert blakey excellent
we're looking forward to hear from
professor blake yeah is he here would
you like to yes
do we have questions we have up until
noon at which point we are finished for
that
i i have a question
yeah
apparently dr blakey now has come to the
view that he was that his investigation
was subverted by the c.i.a
and his his and and his junior councils
were telling him early on that they were
being subverted their efforts are being
supervised and and so it's only late
that he's come to that version but does
does can he or does he
uh really sincerely believe that that
at the time hear it at 1 30 okay all
right yes anybody defend him
dr mellon i'm curious whether you were
able to come to a conclusion based on
anthony viciano's test or testimony you
know i think yesterday notice what i did
jeff morley's sitting back there and so
uh i heard antonio vlasiano say that the
the charade in mexico city was a figment
of the imagination of our old friend
david atley phillips who did the same
thing in guatemala when he uh which is
an interesting story it's in the night
watch by david atley phillips so i
didn't believe so you say oh well i
don't know if did he really say that was
jeff did he really say that so when i
got up you see that and i even had a i
asked him again
are you saying that the events in mexico
city were and were
imagined and created and one of one of
those scenarios say which for which
david atlee phillips was famous which we
know that and he said yes he he he
affirmed it now i don't know i mean
that's what he said
sorry sir can i respond yes
what mr veziana said was he made two
statements
he said he saw oswald in dallas
and he said later phillips talked to him
and said if somebody goes to the cuban
embassy
in mexico city can they get a visa right
away to go
to havana
and vessiana said he said no
vessiana took those two facts and from
those
he made the statement that you said and
what i said was he didn't say that he
said the two statements of fact and
you're taking
his inference which he did say as what
he said and i'm saying
you can take those two facts and not
make that inference that's all i said he
said it's not beautiful yes he said it
twice he said it that's his inference
that's not the two states of fact i
don't know well he has better inferences
than we have since david phillips and
since he talked to david atley phillips
that's fine that's fine if you want to
draw that inference that's fine but i'm
saying the two statements of fact
no it's a fact that he said it it's not
a fact that david you actually think
that he may not be right or that he may
be lying i'm drawing a different you can
draw a different inference from those
two statements that's what i'm saying
with that i think you could you can say
he's lying and he didn't that it isn't
true and that he made it up and all that
you can say that but i don't see why you
should say it he seems so clear so lucid
so certain about the kind of person that
david atlee phillips was sir
yes um
who was it you said that arthur goldberg
asked to replace uh stansfield turner he
was the director of of central
intelligence at the time so you had to
go through the cia carter administration
i'm sorry you had to go through the cia
to
to get on that committee
okay arthur goldberg felt there was no
point in taking up
being counsel of the committee unless he
had an understanding with cia beforehand
and that's why he's calling stansfield
turner thank you thank you
thanks for your talk uh brian bender
with the boston globe
a tough question maybe impossible to
answer but you know my interest in
geoneeds is
whether there is still something
definitive from the government that we
could know about him
and his relationship with oswald there's
been obviously references over many
years
when he talks they will talk about the
three they're not talking about oswald
they're talking about bringing her and
oswald and they're carrying on in the
streets of new of new orleans which were
reported on a daily basis to the fbi and
cia where uh dre comes in he was a
self-styled joiner of dre he did not
represent the leadership of dre and i
wish they were here i wish because i
mean it's just it's to me it's almost
amounts to slander these people were
to me they were young nationalists hot
heads they wanted to
get cuba back from castro they're not
interested in oswald now bringing air is
another story what bring your scenarios
are you have to look in the fbi and cia
records to see what they're doing i
don't know
that's my question it's really more your
opinion
do you have confidence that there are
files that exist
as opposed to having been long destroyed
that would actually
uh delineate some of this relationship
going back to the 60s they're all there
they will go to the files of the
garrison investigation and you'll see
all bringers doings are in there and uh
the fbi
records are there cia's harder to get
but there are some cia records there too
describing their relationship with
bringy air during the summer of 1963.
they are there where shall i ask where
they are
how to find them how would he find them
easily
to the new one
boston globe
we're trying to figure out how how you
can get those records and uh one of the
ways is the uh new orleans field office
new orleans field office of the fbi i
imagine they have to be i've got them at
the wa in washington in maryland at the
national archives but on that on that
point
um having dealt with a lot of government
agencies and classified documents that
obviously the public is trying to get
access to
the official response is that new
orleans would not still have documents
from 50 years ago this is not classified
they won't be classified
i'm talking about the classified the
stuff we haven't seen oh i don't know
yeah
there's a gentleman over here that knows
everything about
documents hello
boston here's the person sitting right
here in the front row later you could
ask him he knows everything there is
about malcolm he knows everything there
is to know
we know that everyone here is you know
he's grabbing his coattails yeah
all right and we have a couple more
minutes okay uh professor melon um uh
going back to antonio vasudeva vestiano
from yesterday um what concerned me
about it uh although the translator did
a brilliant job as far as i know i don't
speak spanish
um a lot of the hair splitting that's
been going on that is going on as far as
veziano is concerned is based on what
the translator said to us now how do we
know
with the best will in the world that the
translator put the right nuances
on what vessiano said especially as far
as phillips and and and mexico are
concerned because
it seems that an argument has been based
on what the translator
nuances were i don't know if you noticed
how good a translator that's sorry it
was a superb translator it was he was
but i'm just talking about the nuances
that a third party puts on
what mr vasiano had to say this is not
shakespeare after all i i i mean yes
everybody but there are many people here
who know spanish too also in this room
yeah even i know some so we everybody's
listening and everybody's i don't think
that's really if it wasn't that
sophisticated no so
you're excited
and remembrance of things past and
something like that
last question right here last question
last question right here go ahead hi um
i was wondering uh regarding
breckenridge um was he in play when
sprague initially took over
and do you have any information about
further information about breckenridge
about his his activities or did he just
get more aggressive when blakey came
into well the documents became there's
some a huge load of documents
of blakey's correspondence i mean a
breckenridge's correspondence with
blackie it's huge it's easy to find is
there more did he contact bruce sprague
i have to confess i don't know that you
could look there's some research that uh
you can get involved into it that's good
one last second this one yes go ahead
i'm assuming
dr mellon that you knew
mr garrison until the end
yes and i'm wondering
because i'm curious was he a broken man
at the end or
what was his
that's a very good question jim garrison
was broken physically
but but spiritually garrison was so
stoical that no matter what happened i
guess it took when he was flying into
those german planes during world war ii
and nazis us firing at him he was
unarmed and won a little reconnaissance
plane and garrison he couldn't touch him
he he he was very unemotional and he
just said to
beerus and delsa
the truth will come out
he was not broken well listen thank you
all very much
thank you doctor thank you professor
john mellen
join american history tv next saturday
for all day live